they were playing with five fouls as
moved to the basket gets two and gets
fouled himself
[Music]
[Applause]
uses the pic beautifully keeps us
defended behind him and lamps are that
one coming
Hayward with the block
of wooden Heywood I mean he's turning
two Jet's goes as hot as he ken
three-point game
wouldn't a were driving on CJ a chance
here
to tie it up crossover little drop good
hands Kyrie skips in ahead to brown
[Applause]
Heyward again take a look hit they were
coming up behind the quick 10 second
difference shot clock game clock Rozier
to the corner
[Music]
[Applause]
but Andre getting up the floor I mean he
was on the baseline guarding against
Norfolk but he ran the floor
[Applause]
[Music]
for a jam except McDermott his outfit
Florida shoot it and that's what Gordon
Hayward is out there forward to school
if there's a Gordon Hayward meter that
meter was almost there audition Terry
Rozier hits up Gordon Hayward is he back
penguin
Tatom doesn't hesitate it's another
three if I've got a bit quickly the
other way
bounce pass picked off for food garbage
trying to write it down too late
shouts get to Milan right is in the sky
set ships with balance shooters phase
stays with a ball kept away in stella by
hatred his second steal the act
surprised he didn't hit the basket are
you going to see right there excellent
defensive play no one says they come
down the floor here right now hot line
drive side on the backboard well he won
the foul he sell the time Washington I
got fouled before I hit the shot taken
for tray again Hayward pushes of sets
him up beautifully player at Utah go to
the high score nice easy pass setting up
Tatum for history
[Applause]
hey we're down the baseline
yes makes matching to the virus comes
away with it
here comes Kyrie throwing it up for
Horford outside Haywood a three
Haywood Boston is within four
mark shot clock winding down
Hayward 15 good at the bus get good boys
bike Orton hey as hey Rick though he's
after dad um I don't know if that was
designed but good read by Gordon hey
we're excited about this just because I
think Derrick Rose has been playing a
lot better
karl-anthony towns and then Gordon
Hayward today's also been playing better
so I think it's gonna be a great matchup
- nice bike coming up by Hayward a
little up fake hits the
the man stood uncontested until the very
end
smarting the pain fatigue with the quick
hands they kick it out Haywood fakes it
kicks it back to the corner Kyrie for
380 dream sex to pass by Gordon rebound
Rozier running away with it gets to
South - trying to have seven straight
points good block I'm gonna always tell
him hey you remember what happened
December 15 anytime I see over here on
now smart tweet from the corner and he
knocks it down
we have been there replacing the ball
gets it to good knocks it down for two
that's a big-time play by smart
ooh brain the childhood exit is right
it's nicely
did I raise degrees as his man
to hear lots of defense can force a tie
here at the half and eight seconds to go
picked off Friday he's got time gets it
off smart Hornets in zone like effective
pulling so far
[Applause]
simple so look at the plaques by out the
reverse screen Gordon Hayward Haywood on
the cut knocks down the jumper
look at these passes that guys are
making dough ball pressure at all
allowing an ended gun so I give them a
lot of credit how you spoke to them
about that today didn't you yeah I
talked to Al Horford about that and one
thing al said is that Billy Donovan when
he was the coach at Florida those
struggling baselines
Belinelli passes up the shot shots come
up with the steal Brown those ears a to
make a tree which was Duke boys towns
with the mid-range jump shot I know
you're sitting there oh he didn't just
say eat one of them
I'm saying yes I did people will tell
you that Al Horford is sort of the hub
of their office but the lead is down to
nine after that bucket
they were probing with the left put it
on a fighter for the layup
mid-range on point nice Drive wait is it
11 stare down three all
[Music]
gorky were to get Brad Stevenson Freddie
he knows she's feeling good
doesn't matter who's out there hey
[Applause]
119 assists through 3/4 score the bucket
he would rate to the rim that's an easy
call and one by Gordon Haley
7 million dollars while the Clippers are
here as a word with the step-back
well he's going to go in tonight Jeff
who sure does with the step back between
the leg they're gonna check if that's a
three Kyrie always wants that last shot
gives it up to Hayward funny how things
change that was of the story a couple of
games ago in Orlando he upset he didn't
get the ball this time deferring to
Hayward for the final shot then Corwin
hey work
he gets his own miss has a clock from
behind stays with it
is the basket and a foul on but here it
is there's a shot
there's to rebound through offensive
rebounds the crowd back into the game
with 220 to go on to have stolen by
Haywood lays it down Tatum for to
Charlotte low putting authority did take
away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
--sykes even what he wants to do he
knows he didn't he wants to be
aggressive out there
Grammy's pass goes awry Brazil the other
way
eight in the shot clock
Morris nice touch by a witch
a mint iced with one time and Hayward
with another cut into Jam the next
Jersey initially committed to Western
Kentucky and changed his mind
hey bird that's the Gordon Hayward the
Celtics are waiting for four-point lead
for Boston here it's wide afternoon
offensively for Gordon Hayward until now
good foot movement by the rookie
hopefully giving a little bit of room
inside Hayward they're unselfish aren't
they get it well that's what they do
here gives up shoots right in the hands
of Berks footrace with smarts go on
about it you stopped Haywood if somebody
coming out of this right and he stopped
instead of continued to attack them
Tatum and say hey
[Applause]
and he's blocked from behind the crowd
is there will follow scan was just other
two to go and the perv
heywood inside enough court ice
the guy I like fixes nose-down air huh
Brown the two they are really trying to
post up smart
and delivers the iteration right here
more it's able to get to the other side
of the lane and Jimmy Butler kind of
caught peek-a-boo a little bit Heywood
got some good looks last night there he
is taking it to the basket nicely done
[Music]
and loaded Drummond beautifully take a
look at Haywood strong moving in on the
reverse side a loose remand off the
bounce sets it out dictated over to
Haywood open look at a tree
[Applause]
hey what a beautiful day with Morrison
open three marketed paints from Bowman
good defense by Hayward nice the
baseball pass ahead to brown brown takes
it right to the beanie and gets do and
we talked to him about hurting players
feelings as we got a three on one
good pass good finish by Hayward that
were you on there
he's been finding to freak people out on
the way that's his fourth going on
loose ball hey we're
the room service at the other end
Mike D'Antoni doesn't like what he sees
here they went out front the tailored
rosier Brown Tatum as well for the
Celtics players past the head look like
and Gordon Hayward from a couple years
ago he was in charge he had the extendo
to get that up over guys just stayed
together next to his job Nate McCall a
pick six right there yeah read that one
here's that pick six we talked about
just hitting rhythms those ain't was
nothing you could do defense spot this
spot but not playing like a fifth seed
here tonight as well here Horford scored
the last eight points for the Celtics
turnover back come the Celtics Gordon
hey were rising with the right hand
Marcus Morris set Dean and bound to fall
[Music]
Hayward driving and traffic hanging 1914
today we're with two seconds left to go
the Celtics up to the Kings Hall a
timeout
we're in Hayward the difference right
here Scott yeah the island got downhill
got a little bit of body contact buddy
hield that was awful deep in Gordon
Hayward rises up look at the body
control and he jumped off one leg snaps
her wrist nothing but net
Haywood
to the basket that's the type of purpose
you need in this game 32:29 three-plus
constantly Hayward will follow a 2 to 5
on the shot clock turned over portrait
right up the middle fine tailors goes
hard to the basket gets to the chopper
on the defensive end by the Celtic the
bird spinning his way into the full
court good hustle by theis Haywood
clears his mane and gets to good job
yeah that all started with the defense
of Daniel tight 17-point Brooklyn Lee
enticing and off the feed from hay with
Isis such great hands
that's good catch it finished guy and I
love the way Gordon Hayward passing the
ball today on its drives off balance
tank into the fall hole for the rebound
still time to go in overtime
Hayward gets inside lays it up and in at
the puzzle it appeared he got it off in
time
and that ends an excellent second
quarter for the selfic second quarter
Celtics outscore the patience 3420
Gordon hey with ten points in the first
half an emphatic finish for Tatum
hangared with another steal
two-on-one Tatum in and does it again
Gordon defending
Hayward's passed ice to chew
[Applause]
sweet heavens in them starting back for
both powers with double team on Tatum
heywhere eyes with the ball fake and
going take Court and Hayward is coming
home and looking very much like his old
center ball fake seat Bogdanovich came
up high as soon as that happens it's
soap night on the shot clock he pulls it
away out gets down hill against Turner
and that's why they brought him here and
you're just happy to see that he's
healthy enough that he can make the move
backs it out against Turner here's the
reruns way shoots it again in the same
result Gordon Hayward says yes this is
my building
we've only got that eight times
Carterton bad instances he's going in
and don't go somebody to the basket by
metal kettle three does not count off
the foul nice pass back door and a word
with the dunk Marv whenever they play
together they get whatever they will
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content